welcome to
the section on neural networks
so a neural network is a non-linear
predictor
y hat is g theta of x which has a
particular
layered form
one way to think about a neural network
is that it
incorporates aspects of feature
engineering into
the predictor
so one way of interpreting this is as
automatic
feature engineering
that's one of the strong reasons why
neural networks are so popular
is that for very complicated
classification and regression problems
it's not obvious what the right choice
of features is and having a
system which can automatically determine
the right choice of features
is very powerful
uh as a consequence of this the number
of parameters
uh which are specify
the particular neural network
can be very large in other words the
dimension of the variable
theta and that means that
p here could be in the millions or tens
or hundreds of millions
and that can make training
difficult and uh
time consuming certain neural networks
can easily take
weeks to train
but however the other side of the coin
is that they can perform very well
uh especially when you have a lot of
data to train them
the resulting predictor that you get
after training
is extremely hard to interpret
essentially it's a it's a black box
it takes in an x and gives you back an
estimate y hat
and how exactly it did that is
somewhat mysterious
uh if you compare that with in
particular a linear predictor
where y hat is theta transpose x then
the meaning of the individual entries of
theta
is very clear tells us
how much increasing certain components
of x
affects the prediction y hat for a
neural network
it's extremely difficult to interpret
what the particular parameters
theta i actually mean
so in a neural network in particular
here we're talking about feed forward
neural networks there are other types of
neural networks which we will see
later in the class so a feed forward
neural network consists of a composition
of functions
y-hat is g3 composed with g2 composed
with g1
of x and that's in the case where we
have three layers but we might have any
number of such functions and those
functions are called
layers we might write this using
composition notation
g is g3 composed with g2 composed with
g1
where the composition operator is
denoted by a circle
some people would call this such a
neural network a multi-layer perceptron
we often write the predictor
composition in terms of individual
variables
you might say z1 is g1 of x then z2 is
g2 of z1
and then y-hat is g3 of z2 for our
three-layer example
and each of these vectors zi is called
the activation
or the output of layer i where layer i
is just the function gi
and zi is a vector it has a
dimension d i which depends on the layer
and those layer dimensions need not all
be the same
and in particular sometimes they grow
and sometimes they shrink
depending on the application
we sometimes write z 0
is x and d 0 is d
the dimension of the number of
features which have been embedded from
the raw data and so we still have a
basic feature map
which constructs x from u x is fire view
but then we don't do feature engineering
typically with a neural network instead
we allow the layers to
provide features which are used by
subsequent layers
in this in the case of our three layer
network we have z3
is y hat the prediction
and then d3 is the number of components
of y hat which would be m
so in particular that means that the
predictor input x
and the predictor output y
are also considered activations of
layers
we might visualize this as a simple
graph where we have
x coming in on the left passing through
the function g1 to generate
z1 which is passed into g2 to generate
z2 which is passed into g3 to generate
y-hat which is just c3
these layers have a particular form each
layer is a composition
of a scalar function h with an
affine function so gi
of zi minus 1 is h composed with theta i
transpose 1 zi minus 1
and this 1 comma zi minus 1 remember
that notation
that notation means if i have two
vectors
a b that's the same as stacking them up
on top of each other
and that means that theta transpose
one comma z means theta transpose
one z
the matrix theta i is uh has dimensions
d
i minus 1 plus 1 by d i
it's the parameter for layer i
and uh the output of
theta transpose one z is is a vector
h here is a a scalar
activation function it takes real
numbers to real numbers
and so the way it is applied to the
vector the meaning of that notation
is that it's applied element wise
so in particular if z
1 is equal to h of q
let me just call it z for the case of
argument
then that means
that z 1 is h of q1
z2 is h of q2
and so on
so when we have m layers in our neural
network we have m
matrices theta 1 through c to m and
those are the parameters that we need to
choose
when training
now we can explicitly divide up
the components of the matrix theta i as
follows
we'll write theta i is alpha i beta i
like this and here alpha i
is uh
is a uh
a row vector so that's alpha i1
alpha i2 all the way up to alpha i
sub di where each of these entries
are scalars but beta is a matrix
and it's uh its entries
are beta i one up to beta i
j and each one of these is a vector of
dimension d i minus 1.
now if we take that notation and then we
say well
we're going to multiply theta transpose
by
1 z so in particular
for the ice layer we're going to take c
to i transpose
multiplied by 1 zi minus 1.
that works out to be this vector
alpha plus a vector whose
components are simply each of the form
beta transpose zi minus 1.
so each one of these entries
of that vector is the linear part
and then there's the constant part here
so just as we might expect for an affine
function
an affine function in general takes the
form
a times z plus
let me not call them that
let me call them
c plus d times z
where d is a matrix and c is a vector
and this is our c and this is
d z
so then the layer map zi is gi of zi
minus 1
means that we take each of the
components of
this affine function here
f i j plus b to i j transpose z i minus
and pass that through the activation
function h
and this sort of function
this sort of function right here it
takes
a vector zi minus 1 as an input
and returns a scalar which is the jth
component of
let's call it a neuron
people often write those
like this what's coming out here
is z i j
and then we have coming in
components of z
i minus 1 1
z i minus 1 2 z i
minus 1 3
and that's a single neuron and
our in our layer has many such neurons
each one of which is giving out a
different component so this would be zi2
this would be zi1 and this
is fed by the same
inputs and so this would be a
layer which has two outputs
and three inputs and it consists of two
neurons now these
constant terms in the affine functions
are called the vector of constant terms
it's called the bias
of the neuron and so in this
layer which has two neurons there are
two scalars
now for i1 and alpha i2 those are the
two biases of that layer
and the betas are the input weights
now activation functions there are two
commonly used
choices for activation functions
um uh they're chosen to be non-linear
in particular if they were linear then g
theta would just be an affine function
of z
which would be a linear predictor for a
single layer and in particular if i
compose
a single layer gi
which is linear with the next layer gi
plus one
well all i'm going to end up with is one
non-linear layer where the two
where the the affine part of the
combined
layer is simply a composition of the two
affine parts
if i put a non-linear function in place
then there's a
difference between g1 composed with g2
which is a function which cannot be
expressed
as a single layer
so the most common activation functions
are called the relu
we've also used this notation a
plus the positive part of the number
a or the maximum a zero and it's
it's this function which we've seen
before
zero when the input is negative and a
when the input is positive
the other very common
activation function is this function e
to the a
on one plus e to the a
which is a smooth function
which varies between zero
and one at zero it's exactly
a half as a
tends to infinity it tends to one as a
tends to minus infinity it tends to zero
it's a scaled hyperbolic tangent
function
we often draw explicitly the neurons in
a neural network
as a graph here's a here's here's such a
graph
here we have a neural network which has
three layers
and we have
this is the output this vector here
is the
feature vector x
then we have z1 is this vector
and so this would be x which is equal to
g0
we map that through
through g1 to get z1
here we have z2
which we map z1 through g2
to get z2 and then we finally
map through g3 to get y hat
and we can interpret on this graph
each of the
edges the lines that connect vertices
within the graph as
having a corresponding parameter
so each one of them would have a
corresponding entry
in the theta matrix in particular here
we're going to see well let's look at
the one that's labeled theta one
two four relates the fourth component of
z1
to the first component of
z 0 which is x and so
each edge has a theta associated with it
but there are also scetars
that live inside the nodes which provide
the biases
so it's only the weight terms that are
associated with edges of this graph
so each vertex here is it's a component
of an activation
and the edges are the individual weights
here's an example of the sort of thing
you see if you construct
a randomly chosen set of parameters
you see one of the function that looks
something like this this is uh
here is we have a three layer neural
network
with two variables x1 and x2 at the
input
and as a result here we have theta
has three uh
three rows the first row
here that's the biases
here are some more biases here are
biases
and the remaining entries are weights so
the second
the output of the first layer the input
to the second layer
is a vector which has dimension four
and then the output
of the subsequent layer has dimension 2
here and then we have an output which
has dimension 1
which is y hat and so the resulting
function is a map
from the two dimensions here
to the one dimension
at the output
it's there's certain terminology that's
very commonly used for neural networks
if you have an
m layer network then layers 1 through
m minus 1 are called hidden layers
layer m is called the output layer
very often if you're doing regression
you
do not use an activation function on the
output layer
or more specifically use the identity
activation function in the output layer
h of a is a in the case of regression
you can see why that is if you look back
at the activation functions we typically
use
if the output layer was using for
example the sigmoid
activation function then it would only
be able to generate
output values or predictions between
zero and one which of course wouldn't
work if we were trying to predict
uh y's which didn't buy in that range
or if we were using value then
we'd only be able to predict
non-negative values
of y hat
the number of layers m is called the
depth
of the network and people refer to
networks which have a large m and large
varies at least three would be typical
as deep learning very often
for neural networks which are used for
say image classification
we may have 15 20 layers or
many more sometimes
now when we're doing training with a
neural network
we do regularized empirical
risk minimization as we've seen before
we pick the
layer parameters theta 1 through c to m
to minimize the empirical risk
with a regularization term added so the
empirical risk
is uh
as always the average loss function
evaluated on the training data set where
g
theta is the neural network map
from input x output y hat
now the regularization term doesn't
regularize the bias parameters
uh the alpha ijs the constant terms in
each of the layers it only regularizes
the the weight terms
and this is because we have
no need to regularize terms which don't
affect the sensitivity
of the network
uh common regularizers is sum of squares
is very common
l1 is also very common um and
in particular with l1 we can expect to
see specification of
the of the neural network
and some of the weights will end up
being zero and that allows us to do
what's called pruning
the neural network simply removing
entries which have zero weight and then
retraining
that might correspond to removing entire
neurons
or just removing particular paths
through the network
typically for the when you're using a
neural network predictor you cannot
minimize the regularized empirical risk
exactly
um uh the the
special case of a convex loss function a
convex regularizer
and linear predictor that's a
very special case in which one can
exactly
find the optimal solution
for the neural network predictor then
even if you have a
quadratic loss and a quadratic
regularizer
there are there are no algorithms that
will
solve the problem exactly um
well so training algorithms instead find
approximately optimal solutions
and these might be local locally optimal
or they might be close to locally
optimal
and we're going to see what methods you
use to do that these are iterative
training methods
and these can take a long time
now here's a particular example this
neural network has i think
four or five layers it's just got two
dimensional
input and one dimensional output and it
was trained on roughly 100 data points
some of which you can see in the plot
and you can see that it's done a
interesting job at fitting it
um of course we can't see all the data
points because some of the points are
underneath the surface
and uh uh
it's it's hard to have any intuition
for what either the meaning of the
parameters
is or how good a fit this is in the
space of our
possibilities associated with a
particular size of the neural network
that we have
all we can do to evaluate how good it is
is validation
now in julia this looks like this
this is a glimpse
at the neural network regression
function that was used to train the
previous example
some things to notice about it
this here defines the network structure
so it says that um
we have uh three layers
the first layer
layer 1 has d
inputs and 10
outputs and a value activation
the second layer has 10
inputs and 10 outputs and also a value
activation
and the third layer has 10
inputs and m outputs where m in this
case is
1 and d in this case is 2. and it has an
identity activation
because we're solving a regression
problem
now what these these um
these functions here the function dense
actually returns a layer function so
when you call it
dense d 10 the activation function value
it will return for you a function f we
could just call it
g 1 equals and then we'll get g2
is dense this and g3
is dense or whatever we called it
and then we might say our overall neural
network let's call it
uh the predictor g we would like to be
g3 composed with g2
composed with g1 now in julia you can
actually type this
that's totally fine if you're if you
happen to know where to get the unicode
symbol for the circle on your keyboard
and if like me you don't then you can
just write
chain of g1
g2 and g3
and that's exactly what we're doing
there so that's just composing functions
and that means that if we want to apply
the resulting
predictor to an input
we just take g which in this case we
called model
let me just call it model
and we could do model of a vector x
and that would be y hat
and so y hat is model of x will
execute the neural network predictor in
return for you the prediction
now the parameters the thetas
are they're not called alpha and beta in
in
flux here we're using the flux library
so before we run this code we need to
type using
flux
the top there the parameters are stored
inside the layer functions
and the way one accesses those is the
following
so in particular i can once i start once
i've composed model is
chain g1 g2 g3 i can get back
the functions i might get them back by
saying g1
is equal to model brackets
one and that
accessing that the first component of
model even though model is not a vector
model is really a composition of
functions
it's been set up inside julia in such a
way that when i access
the first component of model what i get
back
is the first function the first layer of
my neural network
and then i can access its bias and its
weights
its bias is called g1.b and its weights
are called g1.w
and so g1.b is a vector we call the
vector alpha
on the slides and g1.w
is a matrix we call the matrix beta on
the slides
and so you can see here that
we have a regularization function which
is
constructing taking the norm squared of
the weights of each of the layers and
adding those up
and that that's our regularizer
when we want to construct a prediction
we just call
the model function on x that returns us
back the prediction
in particular if i have an x and a y to
to
correspond to a particular record then i
can compute
predict x predict y predict
y of x minus y and that's the error
and i might take the norm squared of
that to compute the quadratic loss
function
and here's my overall objective that i'd
like to minimize
and this function train does the hard
work of actually minimizing
over the parameters and over the data
the cost function those are the things
it takes
the cost function the parameters that's
a special function in flux which
extracts the parameters out of each of
the layers
and there's the data which it iterates
over
and here we return the model
and so we would call nn regression with
an x and a y
and a regularization parameter lambda it
will return for us a model
we can then compute
the corresponding predictions over our
data set we have a function here called
predictal that does that
you give it a model and an x which is a
data matrix
and it iterates over each row of the
matrix x
calls that little x and calls model x
on it to give us a corresponding y hat
and then it stacks all those up to
return for
us a matrix which we might call capital
y
hat would be predictor
predictor of model
x and so if we want to compute the the
rms error for example of our predictions
we call predictor on our model and our
training data
and we compare that with our
true training y's target variables
and we compute the rmse
and so julia's flux library is really
quite efficient
and clean at uh allowing us to construct
neural networks
and you can see that we can construct
neural networks of any size we want
and uh and train them
of course i haven't told you yet how the
training function works
and we're going to defer that uh
discussion of exactly what the trait how
the training function works until
the last few lectures
of the class and but for now we're going
to
use the training function provided with
provided with julia provided with flux
now one way to think about neural
networks is that they really have a very
similar form to
the feature engineering pipeline we
start with an x and we carry out a
sequence of transformations or mappings
to that x
[Music]
and eventually we come out with a y hat
the distinction is is that feature
engineering mappings are chosen by hand
they typically don't have any parameters
or have very few parameters
and you can interpret what they mean um
we might say predict
we might can do feature engineering by
taking the product of two features to
construct a new one and we
know very well that if we take the
product of two features then that
product is going to be large
when both of the individual components
are large
in contrast the neural network mappings
well those are a specific
form that we're not choosing by hand
it's just a it's just a category that we
have
and they have lots of parameters and
we're not choosing those by hand at all
the
training process is choosing the
parameters which is going to determine
the
struct the resulting map
and so one way to think about neural
networks is that they're doing data
driven automatic feature engineering
so one of the very common ways nowadays
of using neural networks
is to use what's called pre-trained
neural networks
um one trains a neural network to
predict some particular target variable
um so say for example one is trying to
distinguish
uh different uh features
in the road from images for a
self-driving car
and one has trained a neural network to
classify
a whole bunch of different road sign
types and a bunch of different vehicle
types and bicycles and construction and
traffic cones and all the other things
one sees on the road
and that training process would be done
with a very large data set
and take some considerable time
and then what you do is you say well
i've got this neural network it's very
large
we're going to fix the parameters and
take that the output of the last hidden
layer
and use those as features to do some
other prediction
so after doing all that training we
suddenly realized that actually what we
need to do is we also need to be able to
distinguish
things we hadn't thought of before a
particular type of road sign
or a particular type of traffic obstacle
well then we don't retrain the
parameters
in the neural network that we have
instead what we do is we retrain
only the last layer
of the neural network or we simply take
all of the outputs of the first
n minus one m minus one
layers of our neural network and feed
those
in as features to some new neural
network
or some new predictor of some other form
and this actually works quite well even
if one is training for quite a different
task
um if one has trained a neural network
to do for example one type of image
classification
then we can often use it to do a
different type of image classification
this is called uh pre-trained neural
networks
uh we saw two examples of these in
the earlier sections when we looked at
vgg16 for images
and we looked at word to vec for english
words both of those were pre-trained
neural networks
and we viewed them there as feature maps
and of course if we're not training
their parameters
that's precisely what they are
so let's summarize
neural networks training needs a lot of
data
and it can be difficult and can take a
great deal of time
and the resulting neural networks are
not interpretable
however they often work really well
better than anything else for many
problems in particular
image classification uh
the best neural networks far outstrip
any other methods that we have
and one way to think about them is that
they're
automatic feature engineering